why didn't you invite her to the wedding
as hard as it is and as heartbreaking as
it is
we had to make a decision that was very
difficult for us
we've been through hell him and i
in the past three years
i love you i love you too
and
i'm not gonna allow
our day to be ruined by this nonsense
the accusations are serious and scathing
dog's daughter claiming he is racist
homophobic and was unfaithful to her
late mother beth who died just over two
years ago did you cheat on beth no
never never she says he began to have an
affair with a friend of my mom's while
she was in the hospital
beth was in the hospital three times i
was there every single second with her
i went home the night before she passed
away with her mother and her sisters
because they said she won't pass away
dog with you standing here so i left
three hours later she passed away
so
when did i have time
i'm a good man
i would have never done that
22 year old bonnie also claims she was
not invited to her dad's wedding because
she supports the black lives matter
movement do you support that
organization yes i do i have never been
a racist i'm
33 and a half percent apache but because
of over 15 years ago i have an achilles
heel because i used the wrong word
well let me ask you about that
at that moment 15 years ago yes sir that
phone call with your son correct you
were using language and over six times
during that call you used the n-word yes
sir why were you using that word so
freely
well i thought i had a pass in the black
tribe to use it kind of like eminem who
gave you the pass the brothers who were
the brothers
i had just you know gotten out of prison
in 1979 after spending
time in 18 months in texas and it was
probably three quarters
from the black tribe
so that was a word that we used uh back
and forth
as
maybe a compliment my past expired for
using it but no one told me that to say
a racist name doesn't qualify to make
you a racist if you use that word if you
use that word and you use it in your
regular everyday life it makes you a
racist i have more black friends in
eminem that is the proximity argument
like i have lots of black friends so
that should make me okay with black
people chapman also denies his
daughter's allegations that he used
homophobic language why would she say
that she's been fed what to say
i have three people that are on my staff
that are gay men
my daughter's gay baby lisa i don't
understand why anybody would ever say
that i hear what you're saying remember
proximity does not
mean that you're not racist or
homophobic would i die for a gay man or
a black man i'd lay down my life
dawg says all this drama started in
march after he had a falling out over a
potential new tv show with unleashed tv
in a statement today the company said
quote mr chapman's own actions led to
the cancellation of his new show bonnie
is still with the production company and
since then has been estranged bonnie is
being brainwashed
bonnie told e.t today in an exclusive
statement as far as the idea that i'm
being brainwashed this is the dumbest
thing my father has ever said we all
have arguments with our kids it's really
difficult
and it's really stressful
but he's worth all of it
[Music]
you